[Music]
let's go out to george in gainesville
florida what's up brother george
hey how you guys doing thank you for
taking my call you got it man what's up
hey so i just found out that i'm being
sued
from a debt collector and i just have no
idea how to approach any of this there's
already a hearing date for next month on
the 11th
um i'm just pretty scared i'm not gonna
lie i know it's not gonna be the end of
the world but i just don't know what to
do
that's pr
well i'll let george walk you through
the letters it's probably not a true
hearing date but why
why aren't you paying off your debts
well so this that was about it was it's
a best buy credit card from about two
and a half years ago probably
um why didn't you pay it off
say it again why didn't you pay it off
um just
straight up i just couldn't afford it
i i'm 24 now i pretty much had to grow
up on my own at the age of 18. so
everything's been at my own expense
almost kind of paycheck to paycheck
since then okay um and i was making the
minimum payments every month
and then cobra kind of hit my hours were
affected a lot
i made eight thousand dollars last year
all of last year
um and i was still able to make it
paying my rent and utility bills but i
just that was it i couldn't really pay
any of my credit card stuff and what
other debt do you have
just so i have the credit card debt
i have a student loan debt
and uh car debt okay hey we're going to
get into your question okay
but but
like can we just pretend you and me and
george are sitting on a table having
some nachos just talking so i can be
direct with you
yeah yeah why are you making 8 000 in
one calendar year
during one of the hottest job markets in
the history of this country
yeah i just um
i didn't have a car until
this uh past february
and um i just to be honest with you i
just couldn't find music transportation
so i stuck i was looking at publix for
about five years i don't think george i
don't think i believe that
because i've had seasons in my life
where i have to ride my bike to work i
was married with a kid but my truck
broke
like you figure it out when you find
yourself up against the wall
yeah
like what what's that what's the hold up
man you're worth more than eight
thousand dollars
you're worth five times pretty much
now i'm actually starting uh january
this past january i just started working
full time for my church
um so that this is the first time and so
what do you make now
i make um 17.50 an hour
okay
well
are you done making excuses because we
can't help you until you're ready to
clear this up man
yeah i mean yeah yeah okay the civil
suit like you mentioned is not the end
of the world but we do have to get it in
writing so i need you to actually well
let's tell what happened here so a
company bought
bad debt for pennies on the dollar from
best buy
okay they sold you owed them how much
how much was the original debt
i don't know what they're original but
the amount they have on all the papers
is 2700 okay so you probably owed 1500
bucks they sold it for 500 and then
they've tacked on a whole bunch of fees
and interest and
they say send you a letter and say give
us 2700
that's what they're doing okay so
they've bought this debt for way less
than 2700 bucks
and now their goal is to see how much
they can extract from you
okay yeah
so george starting today
number one debt is off the table do you
have any more credit cards that are
open no okay
we're not going to touch debt
ever again
yeah agree with that
clearly it's not your friend
it's burnt you too many times in the
past so going forward we need to
actually communicate and take our head
out of the sand and go all right this
sucks i don't like where i'm at but i'm
going to communicate openly and honestly
with this debt collector and say i need
this in writing i need you to confirm
the debt confirm the amounts the age of
the debt and if they can't produce that
then they they have to throw it
out legally but they probably will say
here it is best buy here's the purchases
you made here so much debt here's the
fees and then we go okay this sucks and
now i have to go figure out a way to pay
for this or do you have five hundred
dollars no it's 2700 you have 1500 bucks
cash
what kind of car do you drive
i have a 2014 kia forte okay okay what's
the loan on that
um it was about
9.99
out the door
yeah 9900 and i paid 4 000 um down
payment so you have 6k on the loan
uh a little bit under 5 probably now
okay
so we're going to list all these that
smallest to largest you got to deal with
this one in collections first because
the law is involved this is an ankle
biter
but beyond that if they're willing to
settle let's say 1500 bucks that's great
and they may go all right we're gonna
drop the hearing date this guy's
actually willing to pay us some money
yeah and that's if you call them and say
i'll give you five 1
dollars today that's what i've got or
i've got 980
that's probably gonna be too too much of
a cut for them but
i got 980 bucks i got cash i'll do it
right now you guys send me a contract in
writing that says this will guarantee
this and i will get you paid under no
circumstances do you give them access to
your checking account they'll say i'll
do it but you got to give me your
checking account number no way
if they call them and ask them if they
will settle this thing my friend anthony
o'neil used to work collections and he
said it's best to call at the very end
of the month but you may have a hearing
date before that so
um but call them and just say i'll give
you this much i'll give you 25 i'll give
you 50 i got cash and i'm gonna make
this thing happen okay
and then go ahead george no i mean
that's this is the strategy here there's
no shortcut george we just have to pay
off our debts that we went into and
learn from the mistakes so what do you
do for the church george
i work for facilities so just
maintaining the church in a general
sense what are your
hours i work for i'm a full time so i
work 40 hours a week now what are your
hours
eight to five
oh uh seven to three monday through
friday seven to three how old are you
24 24. you've had a rough go of it huh
childhood was hard
yeah okay
listen to me super carefully
you're at a crossroads
right now
and i spent my career working with young
people okay
i've i'm looking directly at you
you're at a crossroads right now and you
have an opportunity to change everything
your family tree changed the lives of
grandkids you've never met yet you have
an opportunity to work like a maniac for
the next 36 months
when you get off your job at three you
go directly to another job and you get
done with that job you're gonna deliver
pizzas or drive uber until 12 o'clock at
night you're gonna get up next morning
do it again
and you're gonna get yourself something
you've never had which is financial
margin
and then you're gonna start doing things
you've never done before like sleep the
whole night
and be able to pay your rent and not
worry about it
be able to take somebody out on a date
and just pay for it not worry about it
does it sound good
yeah it's a different life but i also
tell you this
if you just park it you get done at
three o'clock and you go home and play
video games you're gonna find yourself
right back where we were
that's my promise to you i've just met
too many guys in your situation you've
got a magic moment here dude but it's
going to take you grinding and working
grinding and working writing working so
here's the deal george and i are gonna
are gonna
shoot you out of this thing with jet
fuel okay i'm gonna give you a year of
uh ramsay plus i'm gonna send you a copy
of total money makeover and i'm gonna
send you the every dollar app for a year
i've just taken away every excuse you
have and i want you to watch these
videos and if you've got some buddies
that would watch them with you that'd be
even better
is that fair
yeah thank you thank you very much could
you go through it with some people at
the church and say hey who wants to do
financial peace university with me
because you can't do this stuff alone
you got to have people in your corner